Dr. Ali, bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Guten Morgen, mein Name ist Günter Meziz.
Ich bin heute hier der Diensthabende und für die zuständige Arzt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen einen analenzen Gespräch führen.
Wenn Sie während des Gesprächs an mich fragen haben, würde gerne ich antworten.
Ich melde mich, wenn ich etwas nicht verstehe.
Melde ich mich.
Okay, melde Sie bitte.
Und bevor wir uns über Ihre aktuelle Bechverden unterhalten, würde ich gerne Ihnen über Ihre Personen und Daten einige Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Jürgen Lausin.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vorname langsam bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname J-U-U-U-Umlaut.
R-G-E-N-Jürgen.
Und der Familienname Lausin.
L-A-U-S-I-E-N.
S-S-I-E-N.
Lausin.
Ich bin ein Mann.
Sprehe Ihre Nachnamen richtig.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Lausin.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 13.02.45.
45.
Wie alt sind Sie?
80.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
76.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Aktuell noch 84 kg.
84 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Fritsch.
Und er hat mich auch hier zu Ihnen geschickt.
Okay.
Was für Bespannung haben Sie?
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Mein Hausarzt schickt mich.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
ich bin in letzter Zeit total schlapp und müde.
Das Essen schmeckt mir nicht.
Ich schwitze in der Nacht.
Ich kann kaum eine Nacht durchschlafen.
Ich bin in der Nacht.
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen
Gewicht verloren.
Ich habe nicht viel Appetit.
Aber das Gewicht ist so richtig runtergegangen.
Trotzdem ist es etwas komisches.
Ich habe nicht viel Appetit.
Ich habe noch ein paar Wochen Gewicht verloren.
Ich habe lange Geb çünkü gemerkt,
dass sie gehört haben.
Ich habe deine Händen gar nicht mehr gezogen.
Das großen liesf.
Ich trage Game everywhere.
Das tut mir nicht weh.
Haben Sie keine Halsschmerzen oder?
Ne, Halsschmerzen habe ich nicht, also das tut mir auch nicht weh.
Aber ich merke, dass das irgendwie alles ein bisschen dick ist.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Schlafprobleme haben.
Haben Sie Probleme mit durchschlafen oder einschlafen?
Ja, überwiegend durchschlafen.
Also ich wache halt auf und bin komplett verschwitzt.
Haben Sie nachschweiß oder?
Ja, ja, sag dich ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Das ist eigentlich ganz neu.
Das ist erst seit zwei Wochen oder so.
Seit zwei Wochen.
Und dann bin ich auch dann wirklich bald zu meinem Arzt gegangen,
weil ich erst habe gedacht, na gut, hast ein Infekt und so.
Aber als es jetzt gar nicht besser wurde, bin ich dann zu meinem Doktor gegangen
und der hat mich dann halt hier zu Ihnen geschickt.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Gewicht abgenommen haben.
Wie viel Kilo und in wie viel Monaten?
Ja, einen Monat, also nicht mal ein Monat.
Und da habe ich fünf Kilo abgenommen.
Also richtig, das ist richtig runtergegangen.
Das ist viel, ja.
Ja.
Und sind diese Beschwerden bei Ihnen erst mal aufgetreten oder?
Ja, so hat ich früher noch nie.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Also ich fühle mich schon so ein bisschen fieberig.
Also ich habe jetzt noch nicht gemessen.
Aber ich fühle mich schon.
Sie haben noch nicht gemessen.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich eigentlich gerade diese Schwitze reiner Nacht.
Also ich fühle mich seit ein paar Tagen habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass ich so
so ein bisschen grühe, ja, so dass die Augen so brennen und so.
Okay, haben Sie Bauchschmerzen oder Brutzschmerzen, Rückenschmerzen?
Also Rückenschmerzen habe ich schon immer, ja, weil ich habe
mit dem Bandschal ein bisschen das zu tun, also schon jahrelang.
Aber das ist jetzt akut nicht schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Haben Sie
haben Sie in Ihrem Halsbereich
irgendwelche
geschwollene Lämpfknoten oder
ja, ich habe es gemerkt, dass es geschwollene ist.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und haben Sie Probleme?
Schlucken?
Beim Schlucken eigentlich nicht, nein.
Also nicht, dass das irgendwie so nach innen drückt oder so, nee, das nicht.
Müssen Sie auch stossen?
Nee.
Okay.
Und haben Sie
Bemerk, das haben Sie
ja, Bemerk
bei Ihnen irgendwelche
Erbrechen, Übelkeit oder Schwindeln?
Nein, also Gott sei Dank musste ich mich nicht übergeben, also das finde ich auch sehr unangenehm.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe keinen großen Hunger.
Ich, also aber Übelkeit, eigentlich nicht, nein.
Und Schwindelgebirge ist mir eigentlich auch nicht nahe.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen
Bauchschmerzen oder Brutzschmerzen oder
Handschmerzen, Handschmerzen?
Nein, also
wie gesagt, Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich fühle mich nur so insgesamt schlapp und
und eben diese komische Spannung da am Hals, ja.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser lassen?
Na ja, also in meinem Alter ist das ja nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Also normal
gehe ich so ein zweimal in der Nacht auf die Toilette, ja.
Aber das ist auch schon länger so.
Das ist jetzt nicht neu.
Können Sie bitte mir sagen, ob Sie
Brennen der Wasser lassen haben?
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Nein, ich muss nur einfach, ich muss nur einfach nur
ja
zwischen durch aufstehen.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Sturgang?
Ja, manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen
Verstopfung.
Dann, wenn das also zu arg ist,
dann hat mir mein Hausarzt so
Movikul Beutel empfohlen.
Nehm ich das und dann geht das auch gut.
Movikul Suspension, oder?
Bitte?
Movikul Suspension oder Tabletten?
Nee, das sind so Beutel, die man so drückt.
Wie oft?
Nein.
Ach, das ist nicht so ständig.
Vielleicht zweimal im Monat oder so.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost?
Nee, Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, nein, also ich habe nur, was ich Ihnen erzählt habe.
Ja, also diese
diese Schlappheit, aber Atemnot habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Und ja, Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie viel schwitzen.
Also Nachts in der Nacht, oder?
Bitte?
In der Nacht.
In der Nacht nur, ja.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie in der
in den Becken, in den Beckenseite,
Flanken, Flanken, oder
vom oralen Seite, ja, unter der Bauch,
irgendwelche Geschwollung bemerkt?
Es mir nichts aufgefallen, aber ich fühle jetzt ja auch nicht ständig,
ob irgendwo was geschwollen ist.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Sie meinen gegen Covid, oder?
Ja, gegen Covid und Kinderkrankheit.
Kinderkrankheit ist ja schon eine Weile her jetzt bei mir,
aber diese Covid-Aufrischung, das habe ich jedes Jahr jetzt gemacht,
aber dieses Jahr muss ich es noch machen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergie gegen etwas?
Ja, ich darf keine Erdbeeren essen.
Das ist sehr traurig, weil ich Erdbeeren eigentlich sehr gut finde,
aber ich bekomme der Ausschlag davon und so, so einen jubenden Hautausschlag
und deswegen muss ich leider auf die Erdbeeren verzichten, ja.
Die Erdbeeren allerergie auser sich mit Hautausschlägen?
Ja, genau.
Macht Haaschwollung oder?
Nee, nee, nee, nur Hautausschlägen.
Atemnöp.
Nein, so etwas alles nicht.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverdraglichkeiten gegen Nahrungsmittel
um zum Beispiel gegen Milch?
Nein, ich kann alles essen und trinken, was ich will.
Haben Sie allerergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nein, also bisher, nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Und rauchen Sie?
Oh, schon lange nicht mehr.
Vor, da lassen Sie mich überlegen, das ist jetzt schon vor 18 Jahren,
ist das sehr, da habe ich mit dem Rauchen aufgehört, ja.
Wie viel haben Sie geraubt, früher?
Oh, ich habe ja schon ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht, ja.
Wie viel Jahre?
Da bestimmt über 30 Jahre, ja.
30?
Ein Schachtel, oder?
Ja, so ungefähr, ja.
Ich verstehe, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also hin und wieder, ja, oder ja, ziemlich regelmäßig trinke ich
so ein Glas Wein am Abend ein oder zwei Gläser, ja.
Und wenn es mal irgendwo etwas zu feiern gibt, trinkt man auch tagsüber mal
etwas, was ich zu einem guten Essen ein Glas Wein, aber das ist
schon die große Ausnahme, ja.
Trinken Sie auch Schnaps, oder?
Nein, so etwas trinken Sie alle.
Nein, nur Wein, oder ja, im Sommer, wenn es ganz heiß ist,
auch mal ein Glas Bier zum richtigen Essen,
aber eigentlich eher bin ich Weintrinker.
Okay.
Für eine vorständige Krankengeschichte muss ich Sie auch
nach Drogenkonsum fragen.
Nehmen Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nee, also wirklich nicht, in meinem Alter.
Nein, nein, damit Drogen habe ich nie etwas zu tun gehabt.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Mannscheibenvorfall haben.
Seit wann ist diese Krankheit diagnostiziert bei Ihnen?
Das ist schon ewig, also bestimmt schon 20 Jahre.
20 Jahre.
Nehmen Sie Ihre
Beide, die sind so 600 da.
600, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, die nehmen sich nicht regelmäßig, die nehmen sich nur, wenn ich wirklich Schmerzen habe.
Das wurde vom Hausarzt verspätet?
Ja, der hat gesagt, ich soll das machen, also damit ich mich da nicht quälen muss mit den Schmerzen.
Okay. Leiden Sie an noch irgendwelche andere Krankheiten,
zum Beispiel Diabetes mellitus.
Diabetes habe ich zum Glück nicht, was bekannt ist und wo ich auch regelmäßig Medikamente einnehme.
Die Blutfettwerte sind so ein bisschen nach oben gerutscht und dann nehme ich Simvastatin abends ein.
Simvastatin.
Wie viel Medikament?
40er, 40er eine Art.
Okay, verstehe.
Wenn Sie get-be-tchen-Medikament dabei bitte ein.
Ja, wenn ich Bauchschmerzen habe, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass der Bauch ein bisschen weh tut,
das hatte ich mal so vor fünf Jahren, hatte ich mal so eine Attacke, da hat mir mein Haus als ein Panthoprazol verschrieben.
Und das nehme ich, also ein, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, so dem Magen geht, ist nicht gut.
Aber ich nehme das nicht regelmäßig.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Das kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen, weil ich das gar nicht immer einnehme.
Ja, okay.
Ich kann auch zum Hausarzt fragen.
Und wurden Sie schon operiert?
Nein, so alt ich geworden bin, aber ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Mit auch örtlicher Betäubung frage ich?
Nee, also gar nicht, überhaupt noch nicht operiert.
Haben Sie schon Mandeln und Militam?
Das ist alles noch drin, ja, alles, das habe ich nicht insundiert gewesen, ja.
Okay, Gott sei Dank, ja, das ist gut.
Ja, Leben ihre Eltern, ihre Eltern.
Ja, das wäre ja ein Wunder, wenn die noch leben würden, ne?
Ja, ich bin nur 80 Jahre alt.
Und meine Eltern leben würden, das wäre schon sehr erstaunlich.
Nein, die sind beide schon lange, lange tot.
Darf ich fragen, warum ihre Eltern gestorben sind?
Ja, also meine Mutter, die war hochgradig Dement.
Und ja, was dann letztendlich zum Tod geführt hat, kann man vielleicht gar nicht sagen.
Und mein Vater hatte ein Kill-Cop-Krebs und der ist mit 73 Jahren verstorben.
Er ist beileitet, ja.
Ja, das liegt ja nun auch schon 10 Jahre zurück, ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich.
Hat sie irgendwelche chronische oder erbliche?
Ja, die hatte, ja, der geht es tatsächlich nicht gut.
Die ist also viel schlechter dran als ich, obwohl die deutlich jünger ist als ich.
Die hatte einen Schlaganfall und ist halbseitig gelebt, ist also schon sehr auf Hilfe angewiesen, ja.
Die lebt zwar noch in ihrer eigenen Wohnung, die ist gut eingerichtet, aber sie braucht also schon viel Hilfe, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin schon viele, viele Jahre verwidert.
Es tut mir leid.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ja, ich bin jetzt natürlich panginär.
Sie sind Räder, ja.
Ja, Sie sind Räder, Räder, aber welche Beruf haben Sie vorgeliebt?
Ich war Mathematiker, ich war Hochschullehrer.
Hochschullehrer, ne?
Haben Sie Stress bei Ihrem Sozelliden?
Nee, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Freibundsregelmäßig Sport?
Ich in meinem Alter Sport, nee, also ich gehe noch regelmäßig spazieren, ja.
Aber das fühlt mich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen schwer, ja.
Ja, wie oft?
Ja, jeden Tag eine kleine Runde, sage ich mal, so 10 Minuten für die Stunde, wenigstens manchmal auch eine halbe Stunde oder eine 3,4 Stunde, je nachdem wie es Wetter ist.
Okay.
Aber die dauert nicht mehr so schnell, ne?
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit nach Ausland gereist?
Ob ich ins Ausland gereist, bin nicht, war immer schön zu Hause.
Okay.
Herr Lausin, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen Ihnen gestellt.
Hab ich noch etwas vergessen?
Ja, möchtest du etwas für Sie fügen?
Ja, ich habe Ihnen ja wirklich so viel erzählt, ich wüsste nicht, was ich Ihnen jetzt noch sagen kann.
Sie haben ja alle wirklich, also Sie haben ja wirklich so viel gefragt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen sollte, ja.
Ja, ich wüsste natürlich jetzt gerne, was los ist mit mir und warum es mir so schlecht geht und was man dagegen tun kann.
Das wüsste ich schon gerne, ja.
Ich möchte erst mal Sie ganz genau untersuchen.
Danach möchte ich bei Ihnen einige Bilkebende verfahren und Blutbechtigung duchführen.
Danach kann ich Ihre Diagnose sprechen.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal diese Prozedüren...
Ja, aber dazu muss ich nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben, ne?
Ja, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, aber...
nach Ihrer Ergebnisse kann ich über diese Frage antworten.
Okay, auf die Frage antworten.
Okay, gut.
Auf die Frage antworten.
Sie können jetzt hier warten.
Ja, ja, okay, dann warte ich hier auf Sie.
Okay, danke.
Vielen Dank.
Ich denke, alle notenige Fragen gestellt, aber vielleicht wurden einige Fragen vergessen.
Würdest du Ihnen noch etwas wissen?
Ja, ich möchte unsere Kollegen fragen.
Hat jemand Fragen, Kollege?
Also ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass es sehr vollständig war, muss ich sagen.
Haben Sie Herrstrasen?
Herrstrasen? Nein, hat er nicht.
Okay.
Ich denke nicht nur Herrstrasen, sondern auch ein bisschen detailliert.
Herrstrasen, Herrstolpen.
Also mein Herz klopft.
Als Klopf.
Klopft ganz normal, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe da keine Besonderheiten gemerkt.
Ja.
Kollegen, bitte.
Ja, ich habe drei erwachsene Kinder.
Weite Fragen, sind sie gesund?
Ja, sind ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, ja, die sind... also so viel, ich weiß, wir sprechen uns ja nicht täglich,
aber grundsätzlich sind die gesund, ja.
Gab es in Ihrer Familie Krebserkrankungen?
Ja, mein Vater hatte ja Kilkopfkrebs, ne?
Ja, und schon.
Ja, okay.
Müssen wir detaillieren,
die Krebs, die Frau Gerhild,
die Krebs, die gleiche, zum Beispiel,
die Halsschwellung der Patient hat,
gesagt und deswegen ein bisschen detaillieren.
La rincassino, oder?
Also ich habe ja gesagt, dass ich keine Halsschmerzen habe,
dass ich aber gemerkt habe, dass da irgendwas geschwollen ist.
Ja?
Ich habe keine Schluckbeschwerden, hat er auch nachgefragt.
Und ich denke mal, dann kann man eigentlich nicht viel weiterfragen.
Deswegen, bei Epikris, können wir sagen,
positive Familien an einem Nese, vielleicht.
Positive Familien an einem Nese?
Ja, natürlich könnte man sagen, ja.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen? Bitte.
Schießen los.
Schießen Sie los, ja.
Aber Dr. Gingel kann auch loslegen mit dem Arzt-Aus-Gespräch,
wenn er fertig ist.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, ich kann versäumen, ja.
Gut.
Ja.
Hallo Frau Obererstin.
Gingel, was ist mein Name?
Ich bin heute bei Ihnen als Assistent, als Tätig.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen, den ich gerade in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Ich möchte gerne Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie da für kurze Zeit?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Es handelt sich um Jurgen Leusin, 80 jährige Patienten.
Das Geburtsdatum ist 3. 2. 1945.
Er ist 1,78 m.
Er wiegt 84 kg.
Er ist 1,78 m groß, ne?
Ja, groß, 1,78 m groß.
Der Patient befindet sich momentan in Beschwerde bedingt der Syrtermalgemeinszustand
und normalem Ernährungszustand.
Er ist seitlich ordentlich situativ und so personvoll orientiert.
Er stellte sich bei uns aufgrund seit 2 Wochen bestehender, dauerhafte, fatig,
diese Beschwerden bei der Patientin erstmal aufgetreten.
Es ist immer noch ein Mann, bei dem Patientin.
Bei dem Patientin, ja, bei dem Patientin erstmal aufgetreten.
Er berichtet über Nachschweiß- und Schweißausbrücke, besonders in der Nacht.
Er fühlt sich kürzlich seit 2 Wochen.
Und die Frage nach dieser Frage,
vomitus, nonzia, vertigo, von dem Patientin fernleicht.
Der Patient leidet unter manchmal Obstipation.
Dagegen nimmt er monatlich Beutel manchmal.
Also bei Bedarf, ne?
Ja, bei Bedarf.
Der Patient berichtet über Schlagprobleme, auch seit 2 Wochen.
Er hat Probleme mit Duschlafen besonders.
Ja, er berichtet über Nachtschweiß.
Ja, und er berichtet pathologische Gewichtabnahme in einem Monat, 5 kg.
Wie viel?
5 kg in einem Monat.
Das ist wirklich heftig, ja.
Aber er hat auch Appetitlosigkeit.
Und er erklärt das auch.
Nach der Angaben der Patientin,
ist er vollständig geheim.
Und er hat eine Allergie gegen Erdbeeren.
Die Allergie außer sich mit Hausausflug,
und in der Noxen Anamnese gibt der Patient an,
dass er einen Ex-Raucher ist.
Aber vorher hat er ungefähr 30 Jahre lang Einschachtel geraut.
Das heißt mit 30 Päckjers.
Er trinkt abends ein Glas Wein.
Und die Drahtkonsum wurde vermeint.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet der Patient
unter Bandscheibenvorfall seit 20 Jahren.
Er trinkt abends ein Glas Wein.
Und er trinkt abends ein Glas Wein.
Und bei Bedarf nimmt er Panthoprosol einmal täglich ein.
Bei der Familienanamnese gab der Patient an.
Bei dem Vater, die Eltern des Patiens sind schon gestorben.
Was ja nicht erstaunlich ist bei einem 80-jährigen Patienten.
Bei dem Vater ist ein Larringskarzinum bekannt.
Bei dem Mutter ist ein Demant bekannt.
Er hat eine Schwester.
Bei seiner Schwester ist eine Apoplex bekannt.
Sie wohnt im Wohnen.
Sie braucht Hilfe.
Er hat Apoplex vollgeschieden hinterlassen.
Er ist verwirrt.
Er hat 3 gesunde Kinder.
Er hat auch einen vorgeschrittenen Leben.
Er hat beruflich Mathematiklehrer gehört.
Reise an Amnese ist unauffällig.
Er ist jetzt Pantho-När.
Er war Mathematiklehrer.
Er hat als
Erster die Anamnese.
Er hat die Anamnese auf einem Larringskarzinum.
Denen kriegt man Alphation, ja.
Lämpfknoten, Vergrößerung anterriert, servikalbereich oder posterior, servikalbereich oder subklarvögelärberein.
Und auch Treutuntersuchung ist richtig, Palpation.
Und ich möchte Karotisoskulation durchführen.
Ah, ja, okay.
Ja, wenn es eine Obstruction gibt oder nicht.
Was machen die noch Diagnostischen mit den Patienten?
Ja, als Diagnostische, bei der Blutbechtung möchtest du die Differenzial...
Ja, was untersuchen sie alles?
Was untersuchen sie alles?
Oder was lassen sie alles im Labor untersuchen?
Differenzial, ich möchte die Differenzialblutbild kontrollieren.
Und auch Infektionparameter, Serep, Prokastonin.
Und Treutwert, TSH, TH, TSH, T4, T3.
Genau, ja.
Und auch nirgendwo die Leberwerte.
Und LDH.
Und ja, vielleicht Amylas kann man für Differenzialdiagnosen...
Gut, was wäre noch labortechnisch möglicherweise eine interessante Untersuchung?
Labortechnisch.
So ein bisschen exotisch?
Bei diesen Patienten, ja, möglich, ja, auch Elektrolyden.
Und...
Okay.
Ja, was machen die Diagnostischen noch weiter?
Ja, ich möchte bei den Patienten heiß Ultraschall durchführen.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Und vielleicht mediasthenoskopie und den Vogogastrodenoskopie.
Ah, ja, das wäre auch möglich, ja, genau.
Und Laryngoskopie durchführen.
Ja.
Ja, wenn es nötig ist,
möchte ich auch Computer-Tomographie mit Kontrastmeter durchführen.
Gut.
Und dann gibt es noch denkbar eine schon eher invasivere Untersuchung?
Wenn Sie an die...
Mediasthenoskopie.
Mediasthenoskopie kann man durchführen.
Mediasthenoskopie, Lampknoten.
Und Biopsy, Feyn-Nadel-Biopsy.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Lampknoten, Exzision kann man denken.
Da kann man drüber nachdenken, genau.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rausgekommen ist.
Also heute machen wir sicherlich nicht mehr als
Blutabnahme- und Halssonographie.
Die CT, ja, möglicherweise kriegen wir heute sogar auch noch ein CT,
aber alle anderen Untersuchungen würde man ja erst dann in den nächsten Tagen machen, ne?
Ja, auch Bauch, Bauch, Ultraschall und Röntgen-Torax-Möfteln.
Ah, da sollten wir auch alle Teller auch noch kurzfristig machen.
Okay, gut.
Ja, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was dabei rausgekommen ist
und dann sprechen wir nachher noch einmal über den Patienten, ja?
Okay, okay, vielen Dank.
Ja.
Okay.
Also, so insgesamt, jetzt schon gleich zur Manöverkritik,
würde ich sagen, Sie haben sich sehr gut geschlagen.
Sie haben ein bisschen über die Zeit gebraucht,
aber nur minimal wirklich.
Der Wecker hat ja immer alarmiert, ja?
Aber ich finde, dass Sie sehr, sehr vollständig gefragt haben
und sprachlich auch weitgehend einwandfrei.
Wir konnten uns eigentlich immer ganz gut verstehen.
Ja, was ich mir so für Ihre Prüfung noch wünschen würde,
dass Sie mich ein bisschen mehr angucken, ja?
Dass Sie so ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit ausfragen
und Ihre Zettel reingucken, ja?
Sondern, dass Sie nach vorne gucken, ja?
Dass Sie den Patienten angucken und ihm so zu verstehen geben,
hallo, ich bin bei Ihnen, ja?
Das ist natürlich mit einem Video nicht so einfach,
wie nachher in der Life-Situation.
Und denken Sie dran, Sie sind der Anwalt,
Sie sind der Arzt und Sie sind Souverän
und Sie haben ganz viel Kenntnisse, ja?
Sie sind der Chef der Lage.
Egal ob da drei Prüfer sitzen und kritisch gucken, ja?
Strahlen Sie selbstbewusstsein aus, ja?
Nicht im Sinne von Arroganz, ihr könnt mich alle,
sondern nein, im Sinne von, ich bin gut vorbereitet,
ich weiß was, ja?
Ich kann auch sehr gut Deutsch sprechen
und ich kann sehr gut eine Anamnese machen
und kann einen Patienten sehr viele Fragen stellen.
Ja, was ich registriert habe,
dass Sie eigentlich schön variiert haben,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass nicht immer nur haben Sie, haben Sie,
das ist mir gleich positiv aufgefallen
oder haben Sie bemerkt und so.
Also ja, ein bisschen, ja?
Die Variation in der Fragestellung,
das fand ich eigentlich schön,
ein klein bisschen haben Sie doppelt gefragt,
der Patient hat Ihnen ja eigentlich erzählt,
von dem Nachtspeis und auch von der Nektorie,
da hätte man also nicht zwingend noch,
also von der Nektorie, haben Sie nur den Oberarzt nichts erzählt, ja?
Aber von dem Nachtspeis, das ist dann eigentlich ja klar,
wenn ich nachts aufwache, weil ich total verschwitzt bin,
dann schlafe ich auch schlecht, ja?
Und wenn ich dann sowieso wach bin
und mein Lasses-Schlaftisch da ausziehen muss
und ein trockenes anziehen,
dann muss ich natürlich auch nochmal auf die Toilette gehen,
das ist ja eigentlich klar.
Also klar, schläft er nicht gut.
Kann man sagen, dass Disomni, kann man sagen, Disomni?
Weiß ich nicht.
Oder Insomni, oder Disomni.
Ich glaube, Disomni sagt man glaube ich nicht.
Aber aktuell hat er jetzt in so einem üblicher Weise,
in der Vorgeschichte,
hat er ja schon über den Nektorie gesprochen.
Er hat ja gesagt,
in meinem Alter geht man immer zweimal in der Nacht zum Klo,
so ungefähr, ja?
Ist ja auch so.
Ich fand das normal, ja, deswegen habe ich nicht zum Fall,
ich habe mich nicht verstanden,
aber ich habe mich auch nicht verstanden.
Ja, aber wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
so ein ganz bisschen holprig war so diese Anfangsgeschichte,
war es ja immer die Schwierigkeit.
Warum stellt der Patient sich vor?
Der Patient wurde vom Hausarzt geschickt,
er klagt über Fatigue,
haben sie sehr schön zusammengefasst eigentlich,
das, was der Patient beschreibt.
Er hat eine Schmerzlose,
Schwellung im Halsbereich.
Das wäre vielleicht noch so etwas,
was man ganz gut formulieren könnte.
Und ja, was sie nicht gefragt haben,
nachdem er ihnen also gesagt hat,
dass er also Rückenschmerzen hat,
dass er erhöhte Blutfettwerte hat
und dass er Panthoprazol nimmt,
dann haben sie sich auch noch ein bisschen über die Schmerzen
und dann hätte er ihnen erzählt,
dass er auch noch regelmäßig Augen tropfen nehmen muss,
weil er eine chronische Binderhautentzündung hat.
Aber gut, ja, Kleinigkeit.
Gut.
Ja, und nachher, also im Umgang mit der Oberärztin,
und dann hat er auch noch ein bisschen über die Schmerzen
und dann hat er auch noch ein bisschen über die Schmerzen,
also mit der Oberärztin.
Da haben sie ja eigentlich sehr komplett
auch die ganze Geschichte wiedergegeben
und haben natürlich auch sehr logisch
ihre Diagnose hergeleitet
und auch das Vorgehen,
was sie alles untersuchen wollen.
Da ist wirklich auch alles gekommen,
was man erwarten kann.
Also tatsächlich ist dieser Fall
ein Hodgkin-Lymphom,
ja, das ist also in der Fallbeschreibung,
aber ich denke mal,
das habe ich ja gesagt, das Laruskatzinom,
finde ich jetzt von der Diagnose nicht so naheliegend,
dann hätte der beschwerden im Hals.
Ja.
Und insofern liegt der Hodgkin irgendwo näher.
Das ist möglicherweise non-Hodgkin
oder eben auch ein Theraetkatzinom,
ja, das aber für ein Laruskatzinom
ohne jegliche Schluck und Beschwerden
kann man sich eigentlich fast nicht vorstellen.
Aber, wie gesagt, bei den Differenzialdiagnosen
war es dabei
und letztendlich dafür machen sie ja auch dann
die Untersuchung, damit sie hinterher wissen,
dass der Patient tatsächlich hat.
Und sie haben sich, finde ich, auch gut rausgeredet,
dass sie den Patienten gesagt haben,
ja, jetzt kann ich Ihnen noch nichts sagen.
Nach den Untersuchungen können wir weitersehen,
dann kann ich Ihnen schon mehr Informationen geben.
Perfekt gelöst.
Ja.
Also, was mir aufgefallen ist,
aber das werden Sie bis übermorgen nicht abschalten,
das haben wir schon oft diskutiert
und das machen alle.
Das ist das Ä, ja, Ä, ja Ä, zwischen durch.
Aber damit, dazu müssen wir stehen
und das passiert halt, Deutsche machen das auch.
Deutsche machen übrigens auch ein Fehler,
den Sie gelegentlich mal machen,
nämlich diesen Umgang mit der Enddeklination.
Dem Patienten, ja,
genau, ich habe einen Patientin gesehen.
Ich habe nicht einen Patient gesehen,
sondern ich habe einen, akkusativ,
wen habe ich gesehen, einen Patientin.
Das ist diese verfliegste Enddeklination
und das ist so ein bisschen eine Ausnahme
von den üblichen Regeln.
Sie betrifft immer nur die männlichen,
die männlichen, die auf Ä gehen.
Es geht die Kollegen, da kommt es, ist es auch nochmal.
Auch bei akkusativ?
Auch bei akkusativ muss man entdecken, oder?
Ja.
Ich wusste ja beim Dativ und Genetiv.
Ja, also eines Patientin,
wem gebe ich die Medikamente,
einen Patienten,
aber wen sehe ich auch einen Patientin?
Ja, also, aber wie gesagt,
das machen viele, viele, viele Deutsche komplett falsch.
Wir reden sowieso viel um Sinn, muss man mal so sagen.
Ja, insofern denke ich mal,
und Sie auf der sicheren Seite,
ich denke, Sie können
ganz gelassen in diese Prüfung gehen,
also wie gesagt, mit erhobenen Haupt
und gerade im Rücken.
Gucken Sie Ihre Prüfer an,
gucken Sie Ihren Patienten an
und seien Sie optimistisch.
Ja.
Was so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, war das bei Ihnen,
das mir manchmal noch fehlt,
ist so diese Satzmelodie.
Ja, weiß ich, ob ich Ihnen das schon mal gesagt habe,
dass Sie die Sätze so da, da, da, da, da,
so, so gleich betonen.
Ja, aber auch das ist so was,
das wird man erst im Laufe der Zeit rausbekommen.
Und je mehr Deutsch Sie sprechen mit anderen Leuten
und wenn Sie Texte hören,
die gesprochen werden, zum Beispiel,
das war sich Nachrichten im Fernsehen,
das sind eigentlich immer sehr gute Sprecher,
da kann man sich eigentlich ganz gut daran orientieren.
Dann haben Sie Beispiele für gute typische Satzmelodie,
kann man so ein bisschen noch verbessern.
Aber wie gesagt, jetzt für die kurze Zeit
können Sie, glaube ich, mit großer Gelassenheit
in die Prüfung gehen.
Ich halte Ihnen jedenfalls die Daumen.
Ja.
Heute sind so viele da, ich glaube, da halten ganz viele mit.
Gut.
Danke schön.
Wenn Sie seit Tabun ist, möchte ich eine Frage stellen.
Ja.
Welche Unterricht gibt es über Weizung und Einweizung?
Also das ist eine Frage für den Kollegen.
Ja.
Einweizung ist für zum Beispiel
für Stationäre auf Nehmen.
Aber über Weizung ist das Ambulant.
Zum Beispiel nach Praxis
mit Überweizung nach Krankenhaus.
Einweizung, ich denke, aber ich weiß nicht.
Das ist grundsätzlich schon richtig.
Nur, die Tücke ist ja eigentlich,
dass es in den Krankenhäusern manchmal auch Ambulanzen gibt
mit Kassenzulassung.
Die brauchen dann tatsächlich eine Überweizung.
Ich finde, diese Bürokratie im deutschen Gesundheitswesen
ist super kompliziert.
Und ja, die, die, oft ist das so,
das sehr kurios ist.
Man weiß genau, ein Patient kommt nur zu einer ambulanten
Untersuchung in die, in die Klinik.
Er braucht aber trotzdem eine Einweisung,
weil der behandelnde Arzt das sonst nicht abrechnen kann.
Und umgekehrt in der Krankenhausambulanz.
Ich erinnere mich an meine Zeit,
als ich in der Gefäßchirurgie im Sekretariat gearbeitet habe.
Wir hatten also eine Ambulanz mit einer,
mit einer Kassenarztzulassung.
Die durften also KV abrechnen.
Und da brauchten wir aber zwingend eine Überweizung.
Die durften nicht ohne Überweizung kommen.
Die durften nicht nur mit Karte kommen.
Ja, also, ja.
Aber grundsätzlich haben Sie das genau richtig erklärt.
Einweisung ist zur stationären Behandlung im Krankenhaus.
Und Überweizung ist grundsätzlich eigentlich zur ambulanten Behandlung
von Praxis zu Praxis.
Genau.
Was man sagen, diese Patienten Überweizung oder Einweisung?
Je nachdem, was der Hausarzt mitgegeben hat.
Das wissen wir gar nicht.
Also, es könnte beides sein.
Das könnte sein, dass der Hausarzt gesagt hat,
gehen Sie in die Klinik, Sie müssen stationär behandelt werden.
Oder, dass der gesagt hat, Sie sollten das im Krankenhaus abklären lassen.
Im Zweifelsfall wird die Praxis in der Ambulanz anrufen und sagen,
Hallo, ich habe hier einen Patienten mit einem Verdacht auf ein Hotkin.
Was brauchen Sie?
Eine Überweizung oder eine Einweisung?
Ja, das wird so sein,
wenn der das nicht alle drei Tage hat.
So ein Fall, dann wird er nachfragen.
Und manchmal ist es, glaube ich, auch so,
das muss ich gerade mal überlegen.
Im Praxis haben wir so machen,
wenn mit dem Rettungswagen geschickt wird,
wir schicken werden,
dann Einweisung, wir haben es geschrieben.
Ja, das ist ja auch sinnvoll.
Denn mit dem Rettungswagen schickt man ja wirklich nur massiv erkrankte Leute
und verletzte Leute.
Aber normalerweise diese Patienten,
Überweisung, wir haben geschrieben.
Ja, und ich meine, wahrscheinlich ist es ja auch so,
dass dieser Patient gar nicht jetzt primär stationär bleibt.
Sondern der wird ja noch fünfmal einbestellt
für diese und für jene Untersuchung.
Und was weiß ich für die Feindadelbiopsie
nochmal an einem neuen Tag und was weiß ich,
der kommt ja noch x mal.
Aber der geht ja zwischendurch immer nach Hause.
Und der wird nicht seine ganze Behandlung da im stationären Bereich haben.
Da sind die ja heute auch sehr sparsam,
weil die Krankenkassen keine Krankenhausliegetage bezahlen wollen.
Ja, ja.
Ja, also das Abrechnungswesen ist nochmal ein echtes Gruseltema.
Man kann nur froh sein, wenn man damit nichts zu tun hat.
Ja, und wie das in Zukunft wird, hier in Deutschland,
der sind ja gerade dabei, das alles komplett umzustellen,
das steht ja auch in den Sternen, wissen wir auch noch nicht, wie das wird.
Da können sie lange mit ihren Prüfern sich drüber unterhalten.
Ja, okay.
Okay, danke schön. Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ich würde gerne zeigen.